thinking about Rick and Morty theories
can get really daunting like remember
the episode with the brain parasites
that you could only identify if you
couldn't think of any bad memories of
them well I don't have any bad memories
of Rick and Morty so does that mean the
show is a parasite oh boy it's getting
weird
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the squatchiest
show in all of squanch your language has
the word squanch in it a lot so with the
new season of Rick and Morty starting
July 30th I've been digging through
everything I can find about the series
and mine is going to some really weird
places like you know Rick created a
micro verse where the inhabitants had to
perform the same repetitive tasks over
and over again to generate the
electricity that Rick's spaceship runs
on well what if our world was created
simply to power another or intelligent
civilization I mean you laugh but
consider this in the show they had to
step on Google boxes in real life what
repetitive tasks came out of nowhere and
now has everyone mesmerised fidget
spinners but that's crazy right it's not
like we have any evidence that fidget
spinners exist in Rick and Morty's the
universe let alone that they were
invented by Rick except I mean what's
that on the jacket of literally every
Rick on the council of ricks but hey
that's just a theory film theory and
feedback up because the episode isn't
over yet putting aside conspiracy
theories about whether our fidgets
spinner crazed society is just a teeny
verse powering a mini verse created by
Rick today I want to look ahead to the
future of Rick and Morty to theorize
about one of the show's most fascinating
and threatening characters iPatch Morty
otherwise known as evil Morty if you
need a refresher course evil Marty's
only appearances in the season 1 episode
closer Encounters of the Rick time
wherein he and an evil Rick assassinated
a number of other Rick's across multiple
dimensions and then try to frame the
show's main rick rick c-137 for the
crime oh yeah by the way fair warning
don't and I repeat do not play a
drinking game or every time I say either
Rick or Morty during this episode you
take a drink I guarantee you'll be dead
by minute 5 anyway by the end of the
episode evil Rick is killed and the evil
morty sneaks away uncaptured blending
into a sea of
Freed's Morty's but here's where it
really gets interesting it's revealed at
the end of the episode that evil Rick
was just a robot and that it was evil
Morty who is controlling mb a-- is
controlling his eyepatch the whole time
clearly that is a huge cliffhanger to
end on and based on what the creators
are saying evil Morty probably won't be
hiding out for very much longer they've
definitely been a little cagey but just
listen to how the creators of the series
talk about this character probably
talked about evil morning in their
writers room more than we actually spent
working on episodes that aired well we
want to come back to something really
cool like like evil Morty I want to make
sure I know what's his motivation what's
this backstory what's going on and it
has to be inspired so it's not a
question of if evil Morty comes back its
Winn
as for his motivations well what if I
told you that evil Morty was Rick's
previous Morty you heard that right the
richest of all Rick Szechuan love and
Rick Sanchez main title character Rick
that Morty with an eyepatch is his
original Morty and that evil Morty's
revenge on Rick is likely to be a major
factor in upcoming episodes oh boy here
I go up the horizon again just call me
crumb Bob ulis Matt past
now before you schwifty a-- strick and
morty fans get all bent out of shape and
fold yourselves in half twelve times I
will say that I'm not the first person
to think that evil Morty used to be
paired up with rick c-137 but well i've
seen the theory i haven't really seen
much evidence for it that makes it much
more of a hypothesis than the theory
really by the same token at this point
enough has been said on the internet
about rick and morty that i can't be
sure that any theory about the show
hasn't been thought up before i mean
there are some people online who believe
that Morty's grandmother is Miss Frizzle
from the Magic School Bus because uh
because summer has red hair and Miss
Frizzle also has red hair and like
science and heck even Arnold got the
unique experience of shoving magic
school buses way up his butt anyway TL
DR even if you think you've heard a
theory like this before you'll want to
stick around because this is the furious
of theories when it comes to tracking
the true story behind evil Morty and
that's the way the
whose goes now you might say off the bat
that there's no way evil Morty could be
rick c-137 s morty because our Rick
already has himself Oh Morty and your
rights except for one thing we can prove
that our current Morty in the show isn't
rick's original in-close Rick counters
when evil Rick is going through rick
c-137 s memories we get a flashback to
Rick picking up Morty as a baby which
causes him to well up with tears not
only is it a really touching moment it's
also crucial for piecing together Rick's
back story based on Jerry crashing into
Morty's room and something Rick AddThis
way comes and also knock next time you
know I mean I'm sitting in here I'm 14 I
got a computer in here you know how we
know Morty is 14 years old and based on
official descriptions of the series on
places like Google Play and Facebook we
see that rick has been quote missing for
nearly 20 years before arriving at his
daughter's doorstep looking to move in
and quote this fact is also confirmed in
the show when Beth says that she I used
to have two drammen two family photos
with a crayon thus the current party
cannot be Rick's original Morty Rick's
been gone for over 20 years but Morty's
only 14 meaning that Rick would have
been around when Morty was a baby
now obviously none of that math proves
that evil Morty is the Morty that we see
in that memory but there are some other
clues sprinkled throughout the episode
that strongly suggest a connection let's
listen to a bit of what evil rick has to
say about Rick's relationship with Morty
we both know that if there's any truth
in the universe it's that Rick's don't
care about Morty's now well that might
initially seem irrelevant remember that
everything evil Rick says in the episode
is coming from evil Morty since Rick is
just a robot controlled by the eye patch
with that new understanding it's obvious
that these are words coming from a morty
who is fed up with Rick one who resents
Rick for the mistreatment he's undergone
resentment that probably comes from
being experimented on tortured maybe
even abandoned let's break those down
one at a time evil Morty is obviously
cybernetically enhanced since we see at
the end of the episode that his eye
patch connects to some wires behind his
eye and we have proof that rick c-137
isn't shy about mechanizing his Morty's
in the season 2 episode the Rick's must
be crazy
Rick lets us onto a little secret about
an enhancement that he gave to Morty's a
long time ago implant
with a subdermal chip that could call
upon dormant nanobots in your
bloodstream to restructure your anatomy
and turn you into a car my god and at
the end of the episode we get proof that
he's not bluffing we also know that evil
Morty is aware of how Rick's camouflaged
their brainwaves by hanging out with
Morty see when a Rick is with him Morty
the genius waves get canceled out by the
[Music]
morty waves how can we be sure that evil
morty knows this because evil morty sets
up a matrix of kidnapped and tortured
Morty's for his fake rank all to make it
seem like the robot rick under his
control was a true Rick committing these
crimes and of course rick c-137 was
surprisingly familiar with this concept
you get a whole matrix of Morty's and
put him in agonizing pain that creates a
pattern that can hide even from other
Rick's like this once on paper morty on
paper he concludes with oddly specific
detail that i mean you can accomplish
the same result with like 5 Morty's in a
jumper cable which i also wouldn't do
sure you wouldn't rick so you say but
take another look at the visuals we get
of rick c-137 s memories and we get
ourselves a remarkably quick peek at a
morty with wires hooked up to his am
getting delivered an electric shock we
know that he did perform this experiment
on our morty our board he certainly
would have remembered it meaning that
the most likely test subject of that
experiment is Rick's first morty evil 40
after all how would he have known that
putting Morty's in pain would camouflage
his brainwaves if he hadn't heard it
from a Rick the cherry on top of all of
this is that it sounds an awful lot like
Rick has had experience with an
overconfidence smart Morty before who
then went on to betray him at the end of
the episode when Morty's looking for
some gratitude from Rick for saving his
life
Rick is fast to shut him down by saying
a cocky Morty can lead to some big
problems can be a real bad thing for
everybody and deflecting any further
commentary by telling Morty he'd
explained it to him when he's older
again an oddly specific detail for Rick
to just toss out there which makes it
seem like he's hinting at the fate of
his first Morty put all of these things
together and what we have Oh Rick whoo
more tea on which he did experiments
including cybernetic enhancements and
brainwave masking tests and an evil more
tea with no Rick of his own who has
cybernetic enhancements knowledge of the
Rick brainwave cloaking and an intense
hatred for all of Rick kind seems like a
match made in heaven there is no God
summer gotta rip that band-aid off now
you'll thank me later but here's the
kicker in close Rick counters rick c-137
s portal gun shows that he's been to all
the dimensions where evil Morty has
killed a Rick he claims he was being
framed and that his portal gun was
tampered with remotely either way it
proves he has a relationship with evil
Morty if he actually was going to the
crime scenes it means he's been
following the comings and goings of evil
morty for a while now if his portal gun
was tampered with by evil morty why why
would evil morty kill all the other
Rick's but then spare rick c-137 why
would his goal be to frame that one
particular Rick because evil Morty
the original morty knows that the
biggest humiliation for the richest of
all rick's would be for rick to be
punished by himself the Council of
Rick's Rick's he considers to be lesser
versions of himself
it's the ultimate revenge for a morty
with an axe to grind
I'm the Rick and so were the rest of you
before you form this stupid alliance you
wanted to be safe from the government so
you became a stupid government that
makes every Rick here less Rick than me
if you like that mind-blowing revelation
well then make sure you hammer Morty
that subscribe button if you don't
subscribe to the film theorists within
the next 30 seconds and I guarantee that
this timeline is gonna divide thanks to
your uncertainty you only have
yourselves to thank so what happened
maybe you Rick was trying to create a
super Morty one just as smart or smarter
than himself to help him take down the
Galactic Federation without the council
of ricks getting in the way he enhances
this Morty mentally in robotic Lee but
then bails when he senses that Morty is
getting too strong or too cruel are too
independent he finds the more deist
Morty he can to disguise his brainwaves
and starts over in a new dimension c-137
that hasn't had a Rick in decades so he
can start again from scratch this of
course begs the question will evil Morty
get his revenge
there you go there's the timeline
subscribe now we have to deal with to
subscribe oh my gosh thank you is
getting awkward in here I'm glad that I
was able to cure your uncertainty now we
can continue with the episode no more
uncertain time line splits will evil
Morty get as a revenge there are already
some clues that point to yes but this
time the revenge isn't gonna come
directly from evil Morty plot twist it's
gonna come from our Morty because evil
Morty's plot all along wasn't
necessarily to kill all the Rick's
himself there's no way he ever could
nope it was to turn all the Morty's
against all the Rick's I mean think
about it why would evil Morty use a
robot Rick in the first place if his
only goal is to assassinate Rick's
nothing about his plot to assassinate
Rick's required anything nearly as
elaborate as an eyepatch controlled
otamatone he could have just gone from
dimension to dimension using the element
of surprise to kill Rick's and still
hack rick c-137 s portal gun to frame
him for the murders it's not like any of
the killings were caught on tape No
by creating a fake Rick that he used to
kidnap and torture those Morty's evil
Morty is able to indoctrinate an entire
army to fight his cause for him and
again what a dramatically perfect way to
overthrow a ring by getting his Morty to
turn on him evil Morty further fans
those flames when the Morty's breakout
and attack robot Rick
remember those words have to be coming
directly from evil morty sounds an awful
lot like he's encouraging morty
aggression toward rick's looks like you
stole a trick or two from emperor
palpatine
doing doing doing but would other non
evil Morty's really turn on their Rick's
in these ways they already have in the
Rick and Morty comics yes there really
are comics of Rick and Morty so if you
still need more of a fix inject those
puppies into your eye holes just watch
out for the eye hole man issues number 7
9 and 10 feature a story arc in which
Morty is transported to a world without
Rick's and seeing the differences
between this world and the world his
previous Rick and destroyed this Morty
vowed to rid the multiverse of all
Rick's we see that resentments bleed
over into the pain Morty in the comics
which I should mention is Morty from
Dimension c130 to a similar dimension to
c-137 but still one distinct from it as
he sees that in a world without Rick he
becomes intelligent and powerful
concluding that Rick is actually holding
him back from reaching his full
potential and as for our Morty earth
Morty we're seeing the same things start
to boil over in the show let's revisit
that scene when evil Rick saying evil
Morty's words confronts rick c-137 with
how to treat Morty's we both know that
if there's any truth in the universe
it's that Rick's don't care about
Morty's now compare that with the words
delivered by our morty in the season 3
premiere when he's spittin some hard
truths to summer about rick he bailed on
mom when she was a kid he bailed on tiny
planet and in case i'd never made this
clear to you summer he bailed on you he
left you to rot in a world that he
ruined because he doesn't care because
nobody's special to him summer sound
familiar
and if you think that's all talk don't
forget that if Rick had given Morty a
real gun near the end of that episode
morty would have shot Rick right in the
head because at this point Morty has no
illusions when Morty's back is up
against the wall he's decided that he's
gonna choose himself and his family
first over Rick whether we get evil
Morty back or not his influence will be
there in earth Morty just waiting to
rear its ugly head
who knows maybe earth Morty will one day
reveal himself to be the real identity
of evil Morty but that's just
speculation in the meantime I'll just
let Rick himself foreshadow it's oh it
gets darker more
welcome to the darkest year of our
adventures but hey not a minute I think
most of us watching this channel can
agree that Rick and Morty being back is
like the best thing to happen to TV
since like the last season of Rick and
Morty seriously when the audience of
this channel gets more excited about
Rick and Morty than it does for game of
squatching thrones
you know you got yourself a dedicated
audience the only problem with that
though is that Rick and Morty is still
just a half-hour TV show
leaving you with 167 hours and 30
minutes of your week to do what dream of
parallel universes where every waking
moment is full of smart funny
thought-provoking well-written animated
series well before you start engaging
with that oddly specific dangering my
friend I have found that dimension for
you it's called the crunchyroll
dimension if you like Rick and Morty
then make sure that you check out one of
their newest shows restaurant to another
world I had never seen or heard about
this thing until watching it on
crunchyroll but basically instead of
going to new dimensions using a portal
gun in restaurant to another world you
go to new dimensions using a grungy
restaurant that's no joke they actually
go through a grungy restaurant where the
universe's weirdest monsters hang out
it's like Rick's portal gun met with the
Star Wars Cantina but then there's also
Dragons and her yeah restaurant to
another world you're gonna want to check
that one out and not only check it out
but check it out in style click the link
in the description to get crunchyroll
premium for free for 14 days or just use
the special link they've given
exclusively to us theorists
crunchyroll.com slash matpat em ATP 80
no more bullet anime episodes with
incomprehensible dubbing off the dark
corners of the interwebs crunchyroll has
episodes one hour after they air in
Japan and super high quality and
practically any device given to us by
the gracious generosity of the big giant
heads in the sky and most importantly of
all no more wondering what to watch next
when the credits roll after a Rick and
Morty episode because crunchyroll not
only has the new stuff but also must-see
anime classics like Cowboy Bebop
beautifully written beautifully animated
if you haven't seen Cowboy Bebop and are
even remotely interested in anime as an
art form it is culturally imperative
that you watch that series now
even if you don't like anime it's an
incredibly compelling story that you're
gonna want to watch from beginning to
end the bottom line is there's tons of
content to cover the time after Rick and
Morty ends and the day after and the
week after and the months when they
decide to take a random midseason break
what even is that by the way what do you
need so many breaks you don't see film
Theory stopping for a midseason break Oh
YouTube your unforgiving click the link
in the description and fill the void in
your entertainment calendar
crunchyroll.com /m 80 P 80
crunchyroll.com slash matpat 14 days of
premium for free and hey that's just a
theory because we don´t get midseason
break suck it up TV people why do you
guys get paid all the bucks